desde el cielo se ven por todos lados
avellanos hasta donde alcanza la vista
en esta provincia a unos 60 kilómetros
al norte de roma el 90% de la superficie
arbórea está dedicada al cultivo de
avellanas
romeo es un emprendedor agrícola antes
en sus terrenos crecían los cereales
pero como muchos en la zona ha decidido
cambiarse a las avellanas mucho más
rentables
la ventaja del cultivo de avellanas es
que no necesita de mucha mano de obra y
no tenemos problemas para venderlas
contrario a lo que pasa con las frutas y
las legumbres que vendemos directamente
al consumidor las avellanas las vendemos
a la industria y eso tiene ventajas las
ventajas son tener un cliente como la
empresa ferrero y el productor de la
nutella encargada de un programa que
compra al menos el 75 por ciento de la
conciencia anual de avellanas algo
atractivo para las más importantes
cooperativas y productores el propio
alto neutralidad cuando el programa de
ferrero busca darle la tranquilidad al
productor para que tenga la certeza de
que su producto será comprado y nos
permite vender al mejor precio bien sin
embargo el monocultivo de avellanas con
alto consumo de agua está acusado de
perjudicar el ecosistema local
es un cultivo intensivo que emplea
pesticidas utilizan tés sustancias
químicas que se vierten en el agua ente
arriba y obviamente por eso favorece el
desarrollo de algunas algas tóxicas que
genera un cóctel de sustancias tóxicas
cancerígenas cancheros la agencia
regional para la protección del medio
ambiente ha confirmado la toxicidad del
agua del lago que alimenta los
acueductos de comunas cercanas sus
habitantes están divididos entre la
preocupación y la resignación cuando
está en el agua no es potable nos dicen
que a priori podemos cocinar con ella
pero tengo dos niños pequeños prefiero
no arriesgar entonces compró toda mi
agua en botella chile-italia tiene
previsto aumentar la superficie de
cultivos de avellana en los próximos
años para llegar a las 90.000 hectáreas
de aquí a 2025